hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to invitationum
invitation
point at the wrong place click at the
wrong time i don't know if that's
intentional the night is dark in the
rain kept hitting the windshield of your
car
an inexplicable breakdown forces you to
stop and to keep going on foot this is
when you spot a few hundred years
yards ahead the glow of a strange
forgotten house in the middle of the
woods
invitation is a short horror game it's
an old-school 2d point-and-click game
created and designed independently and
personally okay cool i'm done with that
warning some aspect of this game's
contents may offend the sensibilities of
young players and viewers you've been
advised some advise this game is best
played with headphones or earbuds and in
low light
one second
that's about as low as my leg can get at
this moment
maybe just that one okay this game does
not feature an inventory objects that
are picked up during the game will be
automatically used by clicking on the
areas where they are required
okay good to know
creation 10 5 4 2
10 5 42
[Music]
[Laughter]
october 1991 somewhere in france
oh
damn it please not now
okay let's stay calm the town isn't that
far on foot where did i put my
flashlight
i don't know it's too dark outside need
a flashlight
uh
yeah there it is
okay
well this is cool
reminds me of all those point-and-click
games from the past ex mortis and all
that a few minutes later
all right
hmm
those lights is that a house they might
have a phone
yeah you're probably right
but also you probably wrong
there's no one there
seems recent
someone else was the same exact problem
that i did well thankfully they went
first so i don't have to die if that's
the case the inhabitants are going to be
pretty surprised to see me yeah
okay
that's probably fine that's no big deal
dear god what is who's screaming like
that
i don't know but this is sign number one
that i should run away as fast as i can
hi
[ __ ] i don't know what that was but
this is weird
i hope someone can help me i hear voices
so that's probably good
creepy
oh
god no
is this a joke
no
they were playing voices on a recorder
that's cruel
ah
yes
that sound came from the lobby right
well if i never look it'll be fine hello
uh i would turn around
[Music]
the
the door
oh
where's the front door
uh
that's a good question it was right
there i swear yeah me too buddy okay
something's not right about this place
there might be another exit somewhere in
the house also there's a key there thank
you
well i don't understand how the door
just
yeah i mean either pal
um
[Music]
doesn't even budge must be condemned
it's locked i don't have the key to this
door
someone removed the photos from the
frames but why
it's not working it's stuck at 3am
who's there peek-a-boo
oh god hi
okay sorry you were in the bathroom i
apologize what was that okay better not
disturb the forces that haunt this place
uh
you're getting really accustomed to the
weirdness pretty quick pictures of the
local area nothing weird
okay sure for now i used the key that i
found in the lobby table it's open now
oh
yeah it's fine this wardrobe is empty
it's locked down under the key to the
safe strange seems attached to the floor
interesting probably a way down it's a
private diary some pages have been torn
out
some sort of jewelry box when i shake it
i can hear something inside
ah
i know what that is
interesting
[Music]
was that it
was that it i don't remember
i'll have to go back and see
that was it
was with that painting
it's weird
it's uh i did have it right okay
there must have been a button to press
okay
[Music]
go
why is this not going i feel like that
should be it why are there two there are
two sets of
there are two sets of heads
oh the shapes
right there are shapes around it i
didn't even notice that okay one second
okay circle diamond triangle got it
that's why there's multiple let's see
circle
diamandi
and
there we go
key but what
the chest
it's locked
okay so not that one that's fine
okay but i do have a key
high bathroom
i don't know why oh well i know why i
always hate bathrooms in these games
it's because they're always haunted
there's always something
there's a key stuck in the drain i can't
reach it i need a tool to get it out
okay
i probably look awful
there are moist half torn clothes in the
bathtub they seem to belong to a man and
a woman
all right awfully presumptuous of you
they could belong to the same person for
all you know it doesn't even budge it
must be condemned
yeah like everything in this place i use
the key that i found in the jewelry box
it opens now
oh i hate this
actually i love this this is great uh
you know i'm going oh god
am i seeing something in the darkness
there hang on
nah nah
seems to be an incense burner the smell
is weird it's making me dizzy
the light bulb must have burned down
[Music]
that's a trap i don't even care if it's
just a normal ass basement that's a trap
all right
there should be a game that's just
nothing but descending into dark
basements because that is the scariest
thing i've ever seen in my entire life
there's nothing scarier than going down
in a dark basement in life in a game the
second place is bathrooms
someone left prince on three of the
alphabetical keys okay three keys it
means there's only six possible
combination by process of elimination i
should be able to find the right one
[Music]
okay
oh
did die
die
it said die
it's telling me to die
dearest member of the host society this
invitation is to be handed over once you
arrive at the temple be punctual one
five two four three six one five two
four three six one two five four three
six one five two four three six i
believe that's important okay
one five two four three six i don't know
why that's important but i bet that's
important some sort of display stand for
a sword the weapon is missing one five
two four three six he's giving me chills
he's so handsome ah that's normal
there's some pliers in this jar along
with
this thing one five two four three six
the lid is sealed there's only one way
to get the tool
well that was
harsh
thanks
oh my god
[ __ ] you piece of [ __ ]
it seems stuck it's not gonna let go
well i know a solution i did break its
home so i guess it's entirely my fault
fuse box seems intact yet the basement
is still dark
it's inexplicable can only be ghosts i
can see something massive prowling
around the house
it's too dark outside to make what it is
well that's news to me
kind of glad that the door is boarded up
now so i got to get something to kill
that all right fine then
that's fine
i'm sorry you want to run that by me
again
who is doing that
there are enough weird sounds in the
house already i should leave it alone
yeah okay
why one five two four three six
hello
i guess i forgot to
check on the thing in the bathroom
that's probably nothing
hi it's me again
okay so that was not there this dude is
here such a tragic look he had to be
that ugly the shadow that's prowling in
front of the house i can't stop thinking
about that scream in the forest i can i
forgot about it already
anything under the bed wardrobe is empty
there's a
no
oh my god i will punch you
i'm coming in to punch
all right tiger decap pro what does that
mean chemical stripper the label
indicates high acidity
well that could kill a thing definitely
there might be something under there
this house is making me paranoid
yeah you know what you're probably right
about that cool well i got a chemical
stripper
i guess a whisper is gone now oh
hi
i'm back again
i might be able to use the chemical
stripper let's put it pray it works
that's got to be painful
[Music]
that thing was at least somewhat alive
frankly it probably needed to die holy
cow
all right well mission accomplished i'm
gonna go venture forward uh-oh
what kind of [ __ ] is this the door
is closed
the key doesn't fit anymore
[ __ ] it stuck
all right good
great
going
i'll kill you i'm punching
oh
[ __ ] no come on move i'm trapped
[Music]
i'm alive
[ __ ]
where's what happened yeah what did
happen
i punched it into a next universe that's
what happened some jars some rags and
what seems to be formaldehyde of course
it is and of course it'd do that
well i'm out of here now
you think you can get me with something
like that the answer is yes
that's revered yes
pliers should do the trick
always does
always does everybody always do
that's one last problem
yeah
okay pro
well that's different
where did the room go
i don't know
the backside of the tapestry is covered
in stains and mold
okay
oh good
oh this guy again still the same
painting this place is getting creepier
by the minute am i even still in the
house
yeah probably not
oh
ah note i'm gonna i'm gonna look at this
and not the giant butthole in the wall
seems to be from the private diary it
begins in the middle of the sentence and
i remember it quite well
winter had already covered the whole
well
the wind was blowing through the top of
the great pine trees
i was pacing up and down bathed in the
soft light of the fireplace the warm
color was contrasting with the sapphire
tones of the drapes the choice i made
that night opened me to me all the doors
that had remained closed until then
that's all i might have something to do
with this colored door okay wait let me
try that again and i remember a winter
only a great snowy cloak white
win but great pine trees green white
green
the soft light of the fireplace like red
or orange
sapphire tones whatever said blue i
think white green red blue well that's
easy okay white green red blue oh white
green red blue what's with the butthole
oh man i'm gonna be sick seems alive
i got any more of that chemical stripper
because that is no
it must good close by okay white green
red blue
i did it the door is unlocked well i
guess i'm oozy
the television is picking up the image
of a corridor wait
it's the one i went through oh no
no
[Music]
no
i see you shadow i say it was your
shadow well that's a problem
[ __ ]
okay
it has to be the same quarter those
things are waiting for me outside
[Music]
well
time for time for a last stand i guess
[Music]
oh
whoa
okay
right
anyway i got a key i think i use the key
that i found in the sink strain it's
open now
one five two four three six
okay
cool
well
[ __ ]
let's hope there's some sort of secret
exit yeah let's hope oh
oh
no down
oh
here we go then hi
hello
how are you good to see you
oh
sorry the delayed flashlight literally
this looks like the altar room from
amnesia the dark descent i'm getting
like crazy flashbacks it's like some
sort of altar
uh-oh
damn it the light so soon
oh
oh good
i mean you're already trapping the house
i don't know how much more trapped i can
be
you are right on time who's there who's
talking
oh hi
how are you
what
where'd
you're the ones responsible for all
those twisted things
we merely are the voices that call upon
the head hunter
every four years we gather to present
three offerings to the great hunter
it is required for the country to grant
our family's safety and prosperity
boy i'm sure glad that you're explaining
this all to me so i can definitely go
and tell someone about it listen i don't
have anything to do with any of this
[Music]
answering the invitation of our
benefactor
for it is known that the suffering
offerings will present themselves to us
guided only by the dark children of the
hunter
[Music]
what do you mean the first two
my dearest members of the hosts society
the time has come
free the altar
or don't
oh good
oh good
well i guess we'll just never know who
that bowl is for
oh i think we're about to know
yeah just shut it all down it's totally
fine
you know pretty easy to uh get someone
trapped when you have the magical
capabilities of sealing up doors at will
and sending them into shadow dimensions
and summoning wall buttholes at will
must be pretty great anyway
i love that i love this style of game i
really do whoa
you'll find random events investigate
them all in the same game in a c oh
hell yeah
i'll do that i'll go through it again
screw that and screw you i'll do it
again hell yeah i wish there was a
tracker though as i was doing it so i
knew which ones i'll just count as i go
that's what i'll do this is really good
it's it's kind of an interesting way to
make games too because it's like it's
simplistic in its execution but
obviously you needed to make the
environment the design of it had to be
done and implemented correctly and that
takes like effort but also it's just
like a very cohesive experience and i
like that about it so what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna try that again i'm gonna
turn on my light
i'm back hello it's me i'm gonna do that
again and i'm gonna see if i can get
this secret ending because i love this
stuff i love it
okay
i just got through it all there's one
spot where i think i might have
[ __ ] it up but i don't know i'm gonna
see because i clicked on literally
everything i even backtracked multiple
times going to different areas that i
had already been to again and again and
again just to see what it was and i'm
like there was one moment where i tried
something a little different in the
basement where i didn't click on the
door as much and i'm just really hoping
it's not gonna count that because
honestly there's nothing else i went
through this with fine tooth comb
the smallest tooth of comb i could
i did it congratulations you have
investigated every element in the game
during your playthrough next time stand
in front of the condemned door in your
house and type the following word happy
okay
i'll do exactly that i don't know what
this is i don't even know if this is
gonna be worth it i put in a lot of work
just to get this so i i'm kind of riding
on this being a good thing
kind of banking on it being fun and
adventurous for me
all right i guess i gotta sit through
this again
okay came from the lobby right and three
two
one
the the the the door
all right hang on
happy
is that music
such rhythm it's coming from upstairs
such rhythm
[Music]
oh
oh
is anyone there
[Music]
[Music]
i love that
that was very worth it this note is for
you well done you finished my game
several playthroughs might have been
necessary to reach full completion you
took time to unlock this off-topic
ending developing a game even a small
one is a path that when walked alone
requires a great deal of patience
invitation
is my first experience of the kind and
making it has been like directing a
short film with lines of code and just
as a movie is made to be seen a game is
meant to be played use some of your own
time to play and finish one of my
creations in its entirety for that you
have my warmest thanks please take good
care of yourself whoever you are
julian barthelini
well thank you very much julian i really
appreciate it that was great experience
i had a good time with that and i hope
you did too link is in the description
if you want to make more of these types
of games definitely go for it because
you do have an act for and this was
quite good thank you everybody so much
for watching check out more scare games
that i've got linked in the description
below and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]